from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between chipotle and the uk and the us
this is food wars
this is a uk chicken burrito we've also
got some black beans some white rice
some lettuce cheese sour cream guac as
well inside we're going to measure the
length the
i don't want to say girls
we're going to measure the length the
girth and the weight of this burrito
so our burrito is seven inches long
i have the same burrito harry has right
here well not the same one the same
order i don't know where the burrito
ends in the tin foil begins i'm kind of
eyeballing it looks to be about uh
between seven and a quarter and seven
and a half inches
a girth of 10 inches
[Music]
it has a gut of
i promise i'm a professional it's
circumference girth really going all the
way around
almost exactly 10 inches burrito is a 10
if you're uh thinking about making it a
tux
and finally it weighs
more than this
this isn't even the big boy
hey
told you guys to get a new scale we got
a new scale bear with us
so we're gonna weigh this burrito half
at a time to see what the toaster is
half one three ten and then this one
that's okay we'll get the scraps from
the plate
[Music]
so combined the two halves our burrito
weighed 597 grams chipotle's burrito
order wade man that's hefty that is a
hefty boy
in the uk we can also get our burritos
in bowl form
this bowl contains the same ingredients
as our burrito but obviously without the
tortilla wrap let's wear and see what it
measures up to
so this one came out to pretty much
exactly 500 grams which even with the
bowl factored in is like 100 grams less
than the burrito so this here is that
same burrito ingredients in bull form
i'm gonna have to go this way oh wow i'm
really smart wait is it heavier
wow so quickly i'm wrong but there's
more here than it was in the burrito
finally we can get our meals in the form
of a salad now this has all the same
ingredients as our bowl but without the
rice let's wait and see how much
difference that makes
strangely enough this cane to pretty
much exactly 500 grams the same as the
burrito bowl and here is the salad
version of that bowl which was the bull
version of that burrito
sticking with me so far
being weed
[Music]
i do want to point out this does have
white rice on it i mean salad is boring
and disgusting i would never get one in
the uk you can only get one size of
chips on the side and it's roughly
this many
some of these are a little bit fractured
so i will just try and form whole chips
where i can
like the banksy of tortilla chips thanks
you've done it again
29 30 and a half
at a u.s chipotle you have two sizes of
chips
the regular
and
the large regular chips first
take forever
all right
a regular bag is roughly 41 chips now
let's count the large
yes
75.76 nearly double for the large bag of
chips at chipotle very nice in the uk we
only get one size of guac on the side
it's supposed to be four ounces we're
gonna measure it to check if that's the
case
ours was just shy of four ounces so
pretty much right the guac in the u.s of
course comes in two sizes as well and
i'm gonna weigh them just to make sure
just to keep them honest i don't know
how much the measuring cup is so it
should be over four ounces of anything
3.75
that's including the cup which correct
me if i'm wrong you do not eat
skimping on the guac
don't act like .25 ounces isn't that
much if it's not that much then put it
in there eight oh zeezers
it's a little over seven
zoom in on that i want to shame these
people shame on you chipotle you're
already charging us extra for it and
you're also just not giving us as much
as we pay for tisk tisk and finally we
have tacos oh hell yeah
when we looked at the menu they were
only available in a portion size of
three in the uk this taco is six inches
in length we got a veggie taco which
includes guac salsa sour cream cheese
fajita vegetables and black beans and as
ways
at us chipotle you can get tacos in
orders of one two or three this guy's
falling apart
it's a six incher and of course
i
did not get
a vegetarian taco this one has meats
aplenty so it has different ingredients
than the one that they weighed making
this weighing completely arbitrary
now this is the biggest burrito you can
get at a uk chipotle we chose chicken as
the base but then we added every other
meat as an add-on and we've also got all
the vegetables and all the sauces they
were a bit reluctant to make this but
eventually they got it done and it seems
to not be leaking so good job guys this
right here is the biggest burrito you
can get at a chipotle in the u.s so big
in fact i named it the big boy got that
fantastic okay what's in it you ask well
it's a carnitas burrito with double
carnitas and i also got double barbacoa
of course it's double wrapped because it
has guacamole white rice fajita veggies
black beans queso blanco
mild tomato i actually got all the
salsas uh sour cream cheese and lettuce
this runs about 18 and 20 cents in the
u.s which is about 13 pounds and
16 shillings this burrito sent me back
16 pounds 75 which is around 22 which is
quite expensive you're looking at kind
of two pounds 70 per meat you add in so
honestly if you're looking for just
quantity for lunch it's probably cheaper
to get two single burritos now it's the
same length as the other burrito coming
in at seven inches but you do get one
extra inch of girth and as we all know
a little yeah
as we all know the extra cat gets along
now i will measure the length
and
uh thickness of this one almost nine
inches okay it's about
eight
and three-fourths yo
this guy's a lot thicker so that's about
eleven and a half inches
of thickness it's much bigger
[Music]
what about the calories well this is the
most popular burrito from chipotle
contains eight ingredients chicken white
rice black beans sour cream guacamole
cheese fresh tomato salsa and lettuce
this contains 1 320 calories 540 of
which are from fat does contain 2 610
milligrams of sodium which is 113 of
your daily allowance and in the u.s that
same burrito according to chipotle is
the exact same nutrition and calorie
count they use the same small wares and
utensils to make the burritos in the uk
as they do in the u.s so everything
should technically be the same that's
what their pr people told us and hey if
you can't trust uh major conglomerates
pr people who can you trust right and if
you got that same order in salad form
and didn't put rice on your salad like a
maniac that would bring this calorie
count down to about 800 and it lowers
the sodium to only 1520 milligrams or 66
of what you should have in the day
chipotle also gives you the option of
having their vinaigrette salad dressing
on the side which adds 220 calories
bumping it back up over a thousand to
one thousand twenty calories and bumping
up the sodium to two thousand three
hundred and twenty seven milligrams or a
hundred and one percent of your daily
and basically it's liquid salt
that's what the geez if you choose to
get your burrito in a bowl form that
loses you 320 calories bringing it down
to an even 1 000. now it's only around
40 of your daily caloric allowance it
still contains
1855 milligrams of sodium however in the
uk a side of chips is 540 calories same
with our regular chips here now if you
upgrade to the large that's going to be
810 calories if you were to enjoy these
with a side of guac that's an extra 230
calories now if you wanted to upgrade to
the large guac that's going to be an
additional 460 calories
now chipotle is a brand prides himself
on being quite a healthy option and not
using too many artificial ingredients in
the us they actually make a big deal of
only needing 53 ingredients across the
entire menu however in the uk when we
totaled up all of the ingredients we
found 67 so as you all know if you watch
food wars that's kind of unusual that
there's more things in the us than in
the uk the only ingredient in the u.s
chipotle that gave me a bit of pause was
something called gypsum gypsum's also
known as calcium sulfate hydrate right
okay and chipotle uses that in their
tofu process when they separate the
chunks from the liquid gypsum is also
found in drywall chalk and shampoo of
course it is now does the gypsum stay in
the tofu or is it just used for the
separating purposes i don't care i'm
never getting tofu from chipotle
put the beast back in front of me
let's look at some ingredients for the
flour tortillas in the uk the tortillas
contain fortified wheat flour which is
wheat flour calcium carbonate iron
niacin thiamine water vegetable oils
palm oil rapeseed oil wholemeal flour
salt and raising agents sodium
carbonates diphosphates and malic acid
in the u.s our flour tortilla only has
four ingredients wheat flour water
canola oil and salt that's it
now i know how joe feels when we film
pretty much all of these episodes
because it's not very nice to have that
many things in your food knowing that
the other side doesn't like why do we
need it but they don't it's weird now
given the fact that we have way more
ingredients in the uk than in the us it
does beg the question as to why the
calorie count for the tortillas is the
same we did reach out to chipotle for an
explanation but unfortunately at the
time of recording they hadn't got bad to
us besides the tortillas a lot of the
other fillings in chipotle have pretty
similar ingredients lists in the uk and
the us maybe with some minor differences
in the spices used for example the
chicken in the uk is flavoured with
chicken water chili arbol and jalapeno
cumin garlic oregano black pepper sea
salt and sunflower oil whereas our
chicken is chicken obviously water
chipotle chili cumin garlic oregano
black pepper salt distilled vinegar and
sunflower oil all words i can pronounce
huzzah our guacamole is pretty simple it
only has six ingredients avocado red
onion jalapeno citrus juice sea salt
flakes and coriander which is what we
call cilantro and we're definitely right
u.s guac is very similar avocado
cilantro or coriander whatever it's
called
jalapenos lemon juice lime juice onions
and salt a serving of white rice in the
uk is made of long grain white rice bay
leaf sunflower oil coriander citrus
juice and sea salt flakes and our white
rice in the u.s contains white rice
bay leaf cilantro lemon juice lime juice
rice bran oil salt and water
finally our monterey jack cheese
contains milk starter cheese culture sea
salt flakes and enzymes don't know which
enzymes just enzymes the concept of
enzymes whereas our cheese contains
cheese curds nope cheese cultures milk
salt and vegetable
rennets
rennets
i don't know if that is
here is everything you will only find on
the menu at uk chipotle these are all
the u.s exclusive items at chipotle now
we only have one exclusive food item on
the menu in the uk and that is the
protein pump bowl
it contains rice a double order of
chicken some lettuce some salsa and some
cheese this first one right here is the
whole 30 bowl for those of you on the
whole 30 diet in the middle
cheat sheet number two this is the paleo
bowl and that is a chicken salad with
guacamole uh lettuce fajita veggies
chicken and the medium green salsa
and the last bowl over here is the
protein pumpkin it's got all that stuff
in it this right here is chipotle's
queso cheese not available in the uk
what is the story with this they figured
out a way to make natural melted cheese
and i got to tell you this stuff
is really good
yeah oh man like the queso is trouble i
love that stuff it's really good a
protein that you can get in the u.s is
carne asada you can get that instead of
the steak and cauliflower rice now there
was no cauliflower rice available at the
chipotles you went to for this video but
besides that i went ahead and made a u.s
only chipotle taco
it's just a queso carne asada taco i
figured a burrito of just carne asada
and queso is a little ridiculous this is
like what i would have gotten when i was
in the seventh grade i was a kid just
like melted cheese and meat and nothing
else so here we go
[Music]
i love the case so it's incredible
carnage that is really good
chipotle also has a children's menu you
can get two tacos or quesadillas i was
surprised to learn with the tacos for
the kids meal you get one meat and two
toppings that yes kids are picky eaters
only two toppings mom and dad only two
also comes with your choice of chocolate
milk
or
apple juice what we lack in exclusive
food options and in fountain drinks we
really make up for in cans and bottles
of drink so we'll start with these
things over here which are tensing brand
natural energy drinks it's kind of like
when you want a red bull slash coffee
but you don't want the guilt associated
with it then we have this very
fancifully named fentimans which is kind
of like a sparkling water flavoured with
elderflower personally not a huge fan of
elderflower but some people are and
that's okay
next we have this turmeric and mango
nourish from humble warrior next up
we've got these cans of dash water which
i think they're just water that's kind
of lightly flavored again we have orange
juice we have berry set go and we have
wonder green if you want something nice
and healthy chipotle's kind of gone for
a fancier vibe with these by the looks
of things these are all kind of the
fancier brands at the end of the day
they are kind of just sodas but they're
ones that are just a bit more up market
than you might normally find a personal
highlight is that chipotle in the uk
sells san pellegrino i don't know if you
guys have this in the us but it's
basically like a brand of sparkling
fruit juices i really love their
lemonade it's like really tangy and
acidic and then finally if you want to
you can finish off your meal with a beer
it looks like the ones over there in the
uk are pretty much different the ones we
have in the us and this is not even all
of them they have the nantucket nectars
i wish it was juice see these are is
izzy you guys had the cans of the sand
pellegrino water we just have the bottle
of the plain which i actually prefer yo
organic black tea
and right here
the best one
mexican coke it really sucks that
america is so obsessed with high
fructose corn syrup because i i think is
similar to mexican coke and just made
with regular sugar would you like a
tortilla chip having been loosely
fondled by me
i